dieses kartoffelröst die Omelette ist so
lecker dafür reibe ich die Kartoffeln
fein so garen Sie nämlich schneller
durch ich schneide jetzt noch eine
Zwiebel dazu die Kartoffeln mit den
Zwiebeln jetzt in etwas Olivenöl
knusprig anbraten geht am besten in
einer beschichteten oder in einer
Eisenpfanne jetzt die Eier verquillen
dazugeben natürlich auch mit Salz und
Pfeffer würzen und das Omelett jetzt von
beiden Seiten ausbacken die Kinder
lieben's pur ich serviere aber
persönlich gerne noch etwas Schmand mit
Lachs und Schnittlauch dazu das Rezept
ist so gut also unbedingt mal
ausprobieren